hey was machst du denn da ich bei
lamborghini ich war auch im lamborghini
lamborghini challenge machen
ok dann losgeht kommt die heutige video
leute haben keine kosten und mühen
gescheut in meiner hand das ist ein
genie erschließt uns ausmacht wenn ich
jetzt hier einmal ausgab clique habt ihr
gedacht wir würden uns einen echten
video aufgezeichnet lukas geringer und
es gemerkt hat an der art und weise wie
gut gefällt würden wir beginnen gerade
einfach drei kleine changes über die
challenge 1 beinhaltet den kleinen
dingen hier auf jeden fall arbeitsplätze
mich schwierig dabei sind die zeit
gestoppt weil dafür jede menge wasser
von ihren vereinen und davon jeder
einzelne brauchen werden um gefahren
werden wer dafür dass krieg wieder den
punkt challenge nummer 1
die alles entscheidende stellen frei
gewordener vorkommende außenklassen komm
raus und dann spielen wir fangen
gespielt so lange bis einer vom
lamborghini gefangen wurde
ich glaube dass wir damit einen richter
um weg zu anfang
ok
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der bereits zweite dabei nicht allzu
schnell aber auch wirklich wirklich
schwierig dafür sehr viel einfacher denn
noch ist nicht klar wie immer fraglicher
filme können ohne eine langsam hoch
weiterwirken seite betrachtet ist das
ist jetzt wieder auch die sieger nie
wieder an der reihe
vorne an erfahrene reicht auch schon
jetzt meine den heiraten
[Applaus]
die erste zeit gewonnen
jede menge marken wie gesagt gewinnt man
sagt dass man müsste da fühlt man auch
im beruf und karriere von fluggästen
wieder irgendwie überlegt da ich jetzt
nicht lachen verteilt habe hintergrund
wird luca dieser runde beginnt das erste
das mir parteien kam dass das ganze zu
schlagen ok den staat verkaufen
das sind kurs element dann wirklich
sagen bis hierhin 3212 direkt mal 34
[Applaus]
ich weiß nicht ich gut wichtig fragen
welche klasse macht wieder hin
okay da steht in vier klassen wieder
auffällt das video jetzt schon gefällt
und das tut es wirklich wegfällt
lukas steht hier direkt an beat werden
dort gedanken klar dass wiederum via
leinwand kommt gewiss schon sehen wer am
ende gewinnt
die wende anders überlegt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für 25-jährige markt damit dass die
dritte stelle wirklich entscheidende
treiber für mich abonnieren wollen weil
sie müssen mich abonnieren wenn ich
verliere und wenn ich gewinne
so leute die nachwelt ist das etwas was
jetzt hier ist man auch mich weiter als
diese skateboard rein in den raum kommt
und dann gleich luca da wo ich jetzt mit
dem namen zu feiern
welche spannung wird auf das
funktioniert ich würde sagen wir starten
ich muss dass man zur seite legen in 32
ein gott
[Applaus]
[Musik]
direkt auf alle ihre kloten 3 2 1
[Applaus]
die tiere würden aber ihre macht sich
niedermüller erwarten anhänger seit der
einsetzung der realität und ich habe
heute ein fester betrag an machen wir
dann hier für eine freikarte geringen
rückgang um ist endlich
[Musik]